[Musik]
hey leute was geht ab märz bekommen bei
einem neuen video
ich war schon ewig nicht mehr hier unten
auf dem sofa aber heute mal das ist
eigentlich so mein lover so traurig weil
immer wenn es irgend was warum ist jetzt
das fenster auch moment ich würde sagen
weil immer wenn es irgend etwas zu
besprechen gibt oder so setzte ich
irgendwie da viele von euch oder ich
weiß jetzt nicht ob es euch bewusst
geworden ist aber man kann ganz ehrlich
sagen ich habe eigentlich das ganze jahr
über
so weisen drei bis vier mal die woche
ein video hochgeladen ich glaube man
kann sogar sagen mindestens viermal das
war halt einfach so im rhythmus in dem
ich irgendwie drin war
ich habe die videos gemacht ich habe
nebenbei gelernt damit ich mich
weiterbilden kann für die union so
weiter und dann kommen natürlich noch
privates dazu und schreibe wirklich
immer der festen überzeugung ich hatte
auch gar nicht das gefühl dass ich
wirklich so gestresst bin ich bin viel
laufen gegangen aber so als ausgleich
jetzt die letzten ein oder zwei monate
kann man nicht mehr so viele videos vor
allem ist die letzte woche habe ich gar
kein video gemacht gestern kam erst mal
wieder 1 das allerdings ja einfach nur
blog war also nichts wo ich mich jetzt
wirklich hingesetzt habe und gesagt habe
jetzt machst du hier aktiv ein video ich
weiß gar nicht wie genau ich am besten
anfangen das zu erzählen ich habe
überlegt ob ich überhaupt erzähle aber
ich finde irgendwie man kann ja mal
darüber reden vielleicht kann das ja
auch einige von euch weil ich habe auch
viele leute oder freunde die mir schon
geschrieben haben oder sogar leute von
euch mir ging das auch mal so ich habe
gestern in dem video schon dieses ding
gezeigt dass ich gerade um hat und auch
instagram haben mich relativ viele
gefragt warum ich das dann trage weil
das sich halt relativ schlimmer aus ich
kann sicher noch mal zu hängen
das sind halt einfach hier so dinger die
ja den herzschlag überwachen ein
sicherheitsdienst schlimmes ich finde es
sieht schlimmer aus als es ist und war
ich vor ungefähr so eineinhalb oder zwei
monaten die phase da habe ich wirklich
viele videos gemacht und habe nebenbei
auch gelernt ich sah es wirklich fast
nur zu hause und irgendwann habe ich
mich dann halt mal hingesetzt auf meinem
schreibtisch das weiß noch ganz genau
und plötzlich habe ich so richtig
gemerkt nicht dass mein herz jetzt
irgendwie besonders schnell schick oder
so aber ich hab den herzschlag gemerkt
und bin wirklich so aufgesprungen und
hat mir alter was man das jetzt und das
war dann erstmal wieder weg ich hatte
dann aber die nächsten tage immer wieder
so dass ich plötzlich einmal kurz mein
herz gespielt habe wie es schlägt also
jetzt nicht besonders schnell oder so
was ich habe einfach ein herzschlag
gemerkt oder das ist halt einmal
irgendwie nicht schlägt kein platt das
ist halt schwer zu beschreiben das war
dann irgendwie bei mir so immer wenn ich
dann plötzlich diesen herzschlag gespürt
hat dass man automatisch so ganz kurz
denkt fragt was war das jetzt wieder und
dann ist es wieder weg
und dann kommt sie wieder und das war
halt an manchen tagen öfter da an
manchen tagen war es weg ich konnte
meine klausuren die zu der zeit
geschrieben aber ich habe die alle
geschrieben ich habe die auch okay
bestanden
aber ich saß wegen der klausuren konnte
mich gar nicht darauf konzentrieren weil
ich immer gedacht habe ich jetzt
vielleicht schlägt das wieder so und
dann habe ich wieder kurz angst dann
waren alle klausuren weg und ich war
noch im urlaub in spanien eine woche und
da war es dann eigentlich weg dann war
ich wieder hier und es war verdammt
heißt wir hatten hier wirklich 37 grad
und ich war richtig ko ich konnte
irgendwie gar nichts machen also ich
habe versucht viel zu machen aber
irgendwie war ich halt durchgehend
schlapp und wenn das dann noch hinzu
kommt dass ich das wieder gemerkt habt
dann konnte ich irgendwie wirklich ich
weiß nicht da kam mir halt eine idee ich
bin jemand ich gehe wirklich um gern zum
arzt und ich gehe auch nicht zum arzt
wenn ich mal husten haben oder keine
ahnung irgendwie dicke mandeln oder so
nun gehe ich nie zum arzt weil da gibt
es ja auch schon heute sagen 'oh jetzt
muss ich zum arzt da muss irgend welche
medikamente gegen nehmen sehe ich
eigentlich nicht so der körper kommt
auch alleine da damit klar meiner
zumindest irgendwann ist es dann wieder
weg ich hatte halt wirklich ein bisschen
angst und habe mir dann gedacht gut
jetzt solltest du vielleicht einfach mal
zum arzt gehen und das habe ich dann
auch gemacht vor einer woche die hat
dann halt einfach so ein bisschen mich
abgehört und auch so einem kurzen test
gemacht die das herz schlägt wobei man
sagen muss es kann ja sein dass das herz
in diesen zwei minuten die man den test
macht ganz normal schlägt und dann
irgendwie innerhalb von 24 stunden zwei
drei mal anders schlägt sie hatten
allerdings gesagt dass es sehr
ungewöhnlich wäre wenn man jetzt in
meinem jungen alter schon irgendwie so
beschwerden hat und dass das eigentlich
nicht sein kann auch auf den aufnahmen
war nichts auffälliges dabei meint aber
ich soll bitte mal so
test machen für 24 stunden und das ist
halt dieses teil weiß ich gerade hier
mit mir tragen und das ist mir jetzt
auch richtig wichtig weil das beruhigt
mich ich gehe auch davon aus dass ich
nichts habe ich denke bei so einer sache
sollte man dann vielleicht das nicht auf
die lockere schulter nehmen ist mir dann
so irgendwann klar geworden wobei ich
jetzt auch wieder sagen kann ich war
dann nachdem ich das erste mal beim arzt
war noch mal fünf tage unterwegs mit
meinen freunden das video kann man uns
doch immerhin falls es noch nicht
gesehen habt schaut sich gerne an und da
ist man dann irgendwie entspannt so und
da hatte ich das gar nicht ja deswegen
wundert euch nicht warum jetzt die
letzten wochen nicht so viele videos
kamen ich wollte mich einfach mal ein
bisschen ausruhen oder versuchen
auszuruhen und irgendwie so an mich zu
denken keine ahnung wobei ich halt auch
denke wenn du dich jeden tag drei vier
stunden hinsetzen videodrehs sollte dass
der körper eigentlich aushalten können
deswegen versuche ich natürlich so
weiterzumachen wie früher es macht mir
auch spaß schreibt mir gerne mal in die
kommentare ob wir so was auch schon
hatte lese ich mir auf jeden fall sehr
gerne durch weil es mich selber
interessiert ja also es ist überhaupt
nichts schlimmes ich bin der festen
überzeugung wir jetzt super und das war
jetzt halt das wetter ein bisschen
lernstress video stress und so weiter
dass das dann halt irgendwie ja dass der
körper nicht ganz so mitgemacht hat
hätte ich auch von mir niemals gedacht
dass das geht ich dachte ich hätte noch
viel mehr machen können aber da wundert
man sich dann halt irgendwie manchmal
also ich muss jetzt gleichauf zum arzt
das ding kommt ab in der stunde und
inhaltlich 24 stunden bin ich mal
gespannt
morgen gibts da wieder ein normales
cooles video ich heute abend noch mal
wieder zurück nach köln
da kann ich halt viel besser videos
drehen als hier ja ich habe mir das
video hat euch nicht sagen nicht
gefallen aber wir fanden es interessant
zu ziehen und so keinen plan und hat
rein bis morgen hatte heute auch absolut
kein skript habe einfach drauf los
gelabert ich hoffe das hört man sie
stark und ihr könnt gut folgen genau hat
rein